fast ein ganzes jahrhundert leben nur
opa heinz in seiner wohnung in hamburg
altona vor vier jahren stirbt seine frau
nach 75 jahre liebe seitdem macht er den
haushalt allein kochen putzen gardinen
waschen
am samstag wird der 100 jahre alt doch
wegen der korona krise muss eine große
feier ausfallen
100 leider kann ich dir aber nun nicht
feiern wenn sie traurig darüber
und auch alle die ich eingeladen hat und
vor allem meine enkelkinder die in kairo
wohnen und leben
und die sind natürlich sehr traurig
haben wir bewusst alles wieder studieren
eigentlich wollte er in großer runde
feiern 53 gäste das restaurant gebucht
die einladungen verschickt nun alles
abgesagt offen für einen späteren
zeitabschnitt dass du machen aber
traurig das ist eben mich am 11 april
stattfinden können aber das ist eben
also eine andere stufe bestimmen wir
nicht das ist jemand anders gewollt er
ist während uns für die eingebrockt hat
wenn man das vielleicht im august oder
september machen können ja aber ob ich
darüber auf dieser welt bin mit meinem
alter das weiß ich nicht jeder tag ist
für mich ein geschenk